a British man died climbing Mount
Everest over the weekend one of a record
number of people aiming for the top of
the world's highest peak Robin Fischer
is at least the eighth person this year
to die during the climb a few days
earlier
Fischer posted this video to Instagram
warning that overcrowding on the
mountain could prove deadly CTM national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is here
with the facts behind that the
fatalities drinka good morning I'm
people yeah and a lot of things to
consider climbing 29,000 feet to the top
of Mount Everest has serious serious
lists of hazards that can cause problems
in a record number of people and we're
seeing more deaths on the mountain than
in recent years the Government of Nepal
issued a record number of climbing
permits this season 381 people were
given permission to ascend the world's
highest peak which can create a log jam
to reach the summit that exposes
climbers to extended periods in areas
with dangerously low oxygen levels
another part of the problem is the
weather expert climbers say May is the
only month where strong winds die down
enough to make summiting even possible
this year that window was shorter than
usual meaning more people trying to
reach the summit at the same time
experts say the combination of the two
factors leaves people in the so-called
Death Zone right before the peak if
you're an oxygen up high on day where
it's crowded and you have to wait in
line you can run out of oxygen and that
can lead to problems to many people one
weather window all in and and and there
are obvious consequences to it Thai
bedside of the Everest is much more
heavily regulated and issues a limited
number of permits but Nepal side is
unregulated and doesn't cap how many
permits are given I think it's so
interesting that mr. Fisher knew it was
deadly so that even posted it on
Instagram right this is a problem but
people do it anyway so you mentioned
that they regulated on one side why does
it nepal regulate it on its side well it
really comes down to money experts we
talked to say the permit system is a
major economic driver for Nepal which is
a very poor country each permit
$11,000 and that doesn't include money
spent on things like food and hotel so
it's unlikely that Nepal will change its
system and lose that economic boom and
since it's unregulated some people who
probably should not be attempting the
dangerous climb can gear up and go
anyway that can also contribute to
bottlenecks as inexperienced climbers
often go slower than seasoned veterans
leading to people waiting in line
climbing experts like Allen Arnett put
it like this he said if you have to
qualify for the Boston Marathon or the
Ironman challenge why shouldn't you have
to qualify to climb the world's highest
mountain yeah an arrogant that line of
people it's like a traffic jam at 29,000
feet it's the experience also I mean I
get it you want to climb the highest
mountain but also isn't it about the
experience man climb the second-highest
it'll be a pretty picture still I
promise but you said everybody they
don't want to be average when I see a
beauty shot from ever so I never think
of it the same way because you see it
look at this it's gorgeous right right
behind you there's a 13,000 people
waiting Clement I thought $11,000 would
weed some people out though is it how
many people can pay that you don't have
to worry about me to pay that I'm gonna
be right here with you at the table
cheering people on jurika thank you